with with a win and defeating the demons
as well as Ally unusual maneuver
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's walked into the ring with a purpose
it was seen to me and his early lad
would say her feet covered the ground
then she walks off
and you're feeding us awesome times it's
intimidation of the women in this
division is that if you cross brandy you
get fish you gotta be kidding me
ally is helpless
[Applause]
[Music]
thank so much got some ducks in the back
recognize the sad music
Oh God
this is literally the immovable force of
the irresistible object
is that fear I've seen the face of
Awesome Kong I know you get a couple of
200 plus pounders then it comes out here
good breakfast
Raja Kong I can't believe this woman
awesome cause standing toe to toe in the
center of the ring to the heaviest
hitters and women's professional
wrestling and now the referees
when their best revetment of coffee
break pursuers coming to separate them
Adams body
let it rip
thank god this is ain't nothing Danny
about this hey an awesome Kong charges
forward forward and I Chacon doesn't
budge she's ready to go
that seems like the only thing that got
up awesome Kong out of the ring was
brandy brandy telling her to wait
telling her that it's not worth it but
right now the the women's division we
saw it earlier on the buy in again
completely upended here with the
returning presence of Asha Kong